hello today I have a special guest that
always not that special and yeah still
Rob here hey he really want to talk
about this episode this is a the episode
the tales of Ba Sing se
I call it 20 stories from Ba Sing se
because it reminds me that Simpsons
episode yeah very much has a Wells like
22 stories at 21-21 so yeah whatever we
call it very much has that feel - it's
just sorry these I don't want some
random stories I mean it's they're all
connect to the characters but I mean no
essential PLAs being move forward and
you were telling me this is your
favorite episode so I want you saying
why it's your favorite episode well put
me on the spot why don't you you're the
guest star well you're the one who's
always going on you will plotz enough
well no I mean pretty much what is it
cuz there's not yeah a bunch of plot in
this one it's just it's little moments
inside there were two very bitchy girls
who got what they deserved
three technically three there was there
was splashing lots of splashing no
that's like there are three girls and
there was lots of square got wet oh we
totally do have a tie everybody yeah
okay we did you feel a bit you um no
yeah this is my hands down I unlike him
I've seen it all the way to the end um
so this was hands-down my favorite
episode um mostly for um heroes story I
was gonna say it's the I yeah I you know
the others are as the others are all
good but that's like the centerpiece
like if this if that was intended this
would not be my favorite episode but
that one piece hands down is the best
thing the entire show will do I'm sorry
I've just destroyed the rest of the
series for you guys is like oh that's as
good as it gets
oh but I know I mean and I really liked
the episode - I the rest of the show's
really really good so I'm not you've got
lots of awesome stuff coming but for me
I mean this bit was it well it is fine
because you were telling me a little bit
about your like you know there's a scene
in
yeah what Eros part in this is it euro
as I said I think it's your I always go
to Japanese way of savings
except for Mako which should be
pronounced Malcolm but everyone said
make us yes and make it which we
probably started I tempted to say zero
but you know you could go I wrote ooh
proper way attic it's a fictional world
no I always forget I row or earu or
anyway they always go you ok ok ok
says so we got uncle yeah let's just
answers if I say dude the Zuka way uncle
so so you got um you got the uncle uh
and yeah that is the best story that's
why could you build me up a little bit
to it you're saying then the uncle story
in this it's really really good at just
like you know I dairy enough to
get a teardrop yeah I was like I dare
you not to get misty-eyed I dare you man
and when it got to his story I'm
stirring and I'm like maybe wasn't
talking about this episode it maybe it
was a different episode about well and
that's what I like is that it really
throws you for a loop and again I think
it's strict if this was to be in any
other show one would possibly look at
the story and be like oh man well that
was clumsy as your Chozen going through
his day all the Sun a tearjerker ending
you know what but it I think it's so
much establishes what kind of character
he is that he can go through his day
very peaceful very well collected and
it's kind of like any other day if
anything it's a special day it says also
it also had the mischievous character my
favorite little moment in there outside
of the ending is when he's playing like
some form of baseball or dodgeball or
something with the clear attending ball
yes Benny and he's like it he's like you
know you know we should fess up and then
confess and you know the earthbender
comes out or whatever ready to kick
their asses like now it's not that time
now is not that time run you know is
brilliant well and I'm wondering if if
my guess is that was always the written
story or what I mean I'm I'm assuming
Mako died obviously in the middle of
doing the voice for those character die
nice give from what I've read it was
somewhere because I mean that's the
thing about voice acting is you can do
certain episodes out of order
I mean you're just recording lines upon
line so somewhere in the last seven
episodes of season two he died as he was
recording the last seven episode so I
mean the big question that I never quite
figured out is is everything in this
tribute episode him well or is there a
replacement or or what was somebody
brought into just spot-check certain
lines I swear
that somewhere in the second season
they've gotten a different voice actor
or maybe just Makos voice has gotten
more clear I'm not sure as it got closer
to the end but there are and if it is a
replacement it's a fine replacement
because it sounds I can't say to my
tongue is this him the credits always
say yet if you check the credits season
three they switch names so all of season
three I know for a fact is someone else
know but a lot of season two it's
crediting him all the way so I don't
know at what point there was a switch
over it could very well be that like
maybe 75% of his lines and this episode
was Maiko and maybe one or two lines in
this episode with someone else and it
works that way through the last seven
episodes depending how far they got i
but it says so obviously they have this
memoriam which I'm all shy they didn't
save her for the end you know that they
added in the middle I was sorry but then
again I sir tires into a story to what
better episode could you have done that
with though oh no no I don't know the
end of the tales of bussing say why
wasn't that the last story oh guys but
again it could tie into how much you
know with him he's just start going
along his everyday life very cheerful
and then he goes to this memorial or he
sets up this memorial for his son and
sings the song I love that that song
they sings that child comes in again
sing it to his son I thought that was
very effective um so at first I was
kinda like why didn't save that for the
end and then what I really thought about
the story knows all sent down like no
that works you know cuz you know for the
end what can be the cliche or having a
hole in the zone Rhys just thinking of
the son passing and nothing else would
be cliched I think what they did really
tied in with the character who sort of
it all encompassing lore I think you're
hitting on part of it I mean there's two
separate things one of you saved them
for the end what a downer
I mean why don't we do that a little
lemur going up but I mean there's still
something cute about Momo that's a
little more crying over his lost friend
it's adorable leader tears are the
cutest I subsist only underneath my
tears no I really I can comparing those
two I still think Momo's is the fluffier
story so I think it was a way to just be
like okay we're not gonna end on this
absolute oh my god uh moment but it I
think so I think part of its that I
think by putting it in the middle you
know you do have a little bit of a
buffer zone because if you would end it
there just for Mako and everything you
just would have been like wow okay I
need a I need a stiff drink after that
um I think the other thing is you just
hit upon it which is you don't realize
as yet and I'm not it's not a spoiler
because I think you're starting to
figure it out by this point anyway that
he is basically the Sam in the Lord of
the Rings story in so many ways this
entire story circles around uncle Iroh
hmm like without uncle Iroh nothing
would happen in this story I mean even
the you know already if you think about
it what would have happened if uncle
Yura was in there
hey avatar probably would have been
captured and you know yeah and so could
that influence that he has on Zuko
wouldn't been there so it's or on top
and that's granted it as it is more than
Katara more than Aang more than even zou
commit euro is the center of this entire
story everything revolves around him and
it'll keep doing that as it keeps going
so he is when you take out whatever the
hundred years element I mean obviously
you have hang in there but Aang
disappears for a while yeah he's sort of
the next to soar come up and sort of
start really setting things in motion
and yeah that is true everything sort of
happens around so to put him in the
center like that he may not be dead
center but to not put him at the end but
still keep him somehow in the middle I
think works just fine for his character
because he's still a character that
everybody's sort of floating around you
know he's the one thing that seems to be
connecting everybody together now what
did you think of the rest of the stories
in this I really liked him I thought
some were weaker than others I
funny I like seeing Katara and Toph sort
of bonding and I thought that story
worked for me that may have been the
weakest of the set though um yeah when
it's all said and done I'm like yeah
that was fun and you know they got to
give her the other you know bullies
their comeuppance but which I enjoyed I
think you kind of need that as much as
you know anger never resolved on no
peace and love and we got to find out
you know all of them they're still yeah
I mean that's the thing there's still
kids and I think that would be a kid
reacts which is they don't kill them
they don't really in all any but only
just gonna drop them in the water
ya know they just not having clothes and
stuff and but you know and I yeah
honestly I think there's a great
anti-bullying message in there which is
you know they're picking on a blind girl
who does this that what the hell is
wrong with for me watching it I actually
surprisingly really liked the the Toph
and Katara story how's that your Alisha
tears I did - I'm just saying it for me
out of that said I thought maybe it was
the ones that didn't grab it there's
only two that didn't grab me uh you know
and they're fine I mean there's nothing
wrong with it they just in grab me is my
oh one was an creating the zoo uh which
was clever but you know just sir I mean
this I like through there's another
example is there something about the
territory yeah they're selling in the
way around something about the top story
and Katara and Yuri sir know the rough
past they had and it's such a good
genuine connection that you feel like
something was something happened there
something has moved forward and the same
you might hear the same thing with Zuko
and the I love his story um you know
again you feel like something has moved
forward that he can lower his defenses
even it's just a little bit and is a
little bitty again he has those mixed
feelings at the end a it shows to how
euro is trying to push him into being
normal he's trying to get into a teenage
boy yeah to accept the fact that you
know you are no longer a prince you know
make your own destiny we're we're in a
tea house in the old bender Kingdom deal
with it you know that's basically his
all stick and so he's trying to push him
into it but I like his story because you
could see Zuko
trying any like he sort of come so close
like maybe I can just have a normal life
dear God maybe all I want as a normal
life as I yeah and I mean this is the
whole theme I think of this season is
Zuko trying to come to terms with maybe
I can give up trying to please my father
trying to you know be the water shame
yeah and you know to see him conflicted
that way and come so close and yet he
still feels like no he's like God can't
do it and I like that you know the uncle
has how did it go how was the how'd your
date going he slams the door and they
opens it up again says is that your kind
of nice and it closes it so it's I keep
my cell phone i Salinas yeah it that
nice mix is nice but I don't want to
admit it the oh I forgot about the
soccer one actually added that was so
short I don't like the sock going to I I
liked it again I mean I don't feel
anything was before but I liked it the
one part where I was like okay shut up
is what I'm watching this out saying
okay this is obviously like a rap battle
back then except with poetry and while
you can make an argument breakfast
poetry but here was and I will say start
no they start doing the rap music and
I'm like shut off yeah don't do it for
long ago just like oh come on but I like
I like as soon as he came in he
accidentally makes over two thousand
five suffering how like as soon as he
comes in he accidentally makes a poem
and then the teacher sort of shows he's
not really anything it was by accident
and then he keeps going and he's good
with it and if it was a very smart scene
but I like how they immediately drop him
as soon as he makes a mistake and
apparently there's like a bodyguard in
this poetry school well that's not I
just like any episode with Sokka because
everyone else and I forget if this has
been addressed yet where you are but if
not I don't think it's a story but at
some point in the series is a mom where
he's like everybody's so cool but me
I can't waterbend I can't hurt them I
can't do anything I have a boomerang you
know that's it and so I love any chance
the writers thrown us to be like let's
give sock a moment it may not be proud
it may not be the great a lot of moments
recently I sort of become like the idea
the crazy idea guy which is totally
welcome well this was an example I think
of and this is where I think the writing
is really clever because even in what
seems like a filler episode it gives us
character because it tells us this is
what he's best at he's thinking out of
the box he's thinking on his feet it's
just a poetry slam but I mean it's
something that he's surprisingly good at
because he has to just he's usually
think on his feet he's usually good at
the stuff he has no idea he's actually
good at yeah and never thought of trying
great at making up as he goes and
that's why I thought the Poetry Slam was
such a great story from his I guess this
is this is his skill set I make up
as I go
no and then the and the mobile story I'm
not sure what it looks like he's looking
for up and he comes across these other
little Panther bat whatever they are um
and he helps them out and they take the
fur and lead him to I think it's a
footprint I think is what it is somehow
there's only one thing I might need to
fulfill or something um and I guess he's
supposed to serve be missing him I'm not
sure how there's only one footprint
there or it's hard to gather the size if
you like fell over or what but I'm like
did I read that right that that if the
area where Appa used to be and Momo
feels bad and sits there is that what's
going on there
yes okay I I want to beat Rick how you
wanting to pick up a man I don't know
look cuz there's only one footprint um I
shouldn't it be like three or more it
was a muddy patch there were bricks
everywhere else but just in that one
little big pile of mud I don't know it
seemed like there should be more foot
for all to be explained after oppas lost
days that always seems to be the thing
it's always like oh it's I just tell you
wait and so I'm trying to do that trying
to be like pipes like almost osho makes
it really tough to give criticism
because it's like up it will come in
later outfit
coming later it's like I'm actually rqu
with Dante ingenious show yeah I'm
really hard-pressed to think of things
that don't come back there may be one or
two things I'm like yeah I guess that
really didn't come back but pretty much
like almost everything you've brought up
I'm like yeah that comes back that comes
back that comes back and I know you're
not I don't think you're not reading the
comments are you cuz there's spoilers oh
no every once a while
I'm telling you guys right now if you're
posting comments look oh no just you
wait this is he's not reading them
because you guys are smelling like it
the only thing I ever see is edgy just
that just oh just wait oh just wait so
it's like I don't worried okay that's
like the thing I have passed on the
message as well just wait so you guys
can keep typing that all you want but
you know it's he gets it oh wait always
yeah but know that all of that will be
explained that uh that's a great that's
a dark episode - well show ya oppas lost
days hey IKEA I can't say it was
supposed to if I got those last days
like what suppose go oh no I'm sorry not
last days lost eight well gosh I've lost
something it's just supposed to look
like it and a actually now I'm just
realizing why actually that makes sense
now when I'm thinking about the way they
set up these stories of course Momo's
would be less because that leads
directly into the next one oh there you
go if you really throw all these stories
together that leads directly into next
one I think being a little more light
hundred with Momo is good because oppas
lost days oh my god oh my god
gets real um tickly for your bison
so I would say that you know and a lot
of these episodes you know I start to
talk about filler episodes and but I
don't talk them in like in bad ways I
say a fellow can be good if it really is
furthering character not necessarily has
to further also as if we're declaring
this a filler episode of making a
greatest filler episode of anything I've
everything I'm saying that this really
does I'm saying that they're not only
not bad but a lot of times they're
essential and I don't know if I
necessarily call this I might call it a
little bit of a filler but again we just
need those moments for characters to
relax I mean this is why something like
this Star Trek works so much better as
like a show that does a movie which I
mean there's a lot of good movies but
like you compare next generation the
show to the movies it's like next
generation
you can just have an episode about Troy
or Worf or something like that you can
have the characters just breathe and you
really need that in order to want to
follow them I think this was a good
example of just letting the characters
breathe and find out stuff about them
you would have known before like I said
the thing with Tyler I'm not I never
really thought about I will argue this
Toph Sokka um Katara
yeah Katara I even Zuko's I think is a
little more necessary
you could argue I think in this episode
that that could quite possibly be fill a
really good filler but you could argue
could have found a way to maybe
incorporate that into a main plotline
elsewhere Momo story you couldn't then
actually is advancing the plot being
you'll find out why in the next episode
but Eros story no I don't think there's
anything filler about that at all I
think once you see the whole thing put
together the entire series and you look
back at this episode you will realize
that if you were to ask somebody if
someone was to ask you what is avatar
about if somebody were to ask me bad
having seen the series I would say watch
the whole thing but when you want to get
down to what avatar is about watch that
episode particularly euros story like
his character and what he does basically
is what the entire show is about I mean
when you get down to it it is a non
violent anti-war message the whole way
through
no spoilers no yeah because that gives
something away yeah I I mean he
encompasses the soul of the story and
basically I don't even know how to
define this it's just he is the story
like the funny thing is for a show that
has so many kids in it and revolves
around kids he basically is the center
on which the story spins around and he
is the only adult because if you look at
the show for the most part most of the
adults tend to make mistakes or most of
the adults tend to be douchebags
um you'll even find this out you know
about people hang idolizes you know you
look in and be like huh like kind of
expected more out of the adults in the
room he's the only adult who is at a
stage I think in the game of this show
who basically is on the same level as
the rest of the kids why these are the
chili kit isn't yeah as the childlike
innocence and he is the only adult that
you know sets himself apart from the
rest of the adults in them and that's
why I think this is such a powerful
episode from because up until this point
I was pretty much like this is a good
show I mean this is a really really
really good show this episode and that
bit in this episode in particular was
the point where I went okay this is not
a really really good show this is one of
the greatest shows I've ever seen and
that did not happen until this episode
and is great as the rest of the series
is I'm not sure it had a point that it
was ever quite as good as that one
moment again it's like this is the heart
and soul of the whole series right in
this episode which is why I think it's
the best
oh say Otis so there it is another
really good episode you'd be even a
great episode right there um yeah and
there's any more episodes that Rob wants
to come in and get you all to cry at uh
he will return and what do you review
next uh well is it the lot well okay
though wasn't lost Appa
what's a cold oppas lost elbows lost
days yes that'll be the next one um you
never studied